listen let's start
bill cosby's out of jail
my [ __ ] out
and i i saw that like he's thinking
about touring yeah but he's gotta wait
for r kelly so they can do the best the
worst worlds tour and that'd be crazy it
would bro that would go up i'm not gonna
lie i always say this i love r kelly's
music i appreciate him as an artist yeah
i never was like a huge like i think i
grew up like a little bit past the cosby
show so that wasn't like i was like
right before like my childhood so i
really never really cared about bill
cosby that's kind of like kelly's the
goat yeah that's kind of like me and o.j
like i wasn't a fan before like i heard
about the murders and i was just like so
i know yeah all i know is he killed this
white woman and then her boyfriend yeah
oh he remember 2000 yards okay that's
cool yeah i wasn't watching [ __ ] usc
football murder that season that shit's
crazy no but you think do you think bill
cosby could like do a successful
stand-up tour
yeah like the chitlin circuit bring that
[ __ ] back you know what i mean like
people would like i think people would
pay to see him but do you think
promoters would book him or do you think
they'd be afraid of the outrage black
people are so forgiving they support
that dude i mean like listen
he's a monster i don't know what's gonna
happen but you know monsters have fans
too i bet if jeffrey dahmer was out
there or ted bunny were out there [ __ ]
would have [ __ ] fans too